- Hi, everyone, This is Jeremy
Schifeling at Khan Academy.
Thanks for taking time
out of the first week
of back to school
or the third week,
depending on where you are.
Wherever you're coming
from we're super excited
to have you with us this
afternoon or this evening.
And we're extremely lucky
to have our chief learning
officer Kristin joining us
to share with you some
really powerful strategies
for motivating your students,
especially during this challenging moment.
Now, because Kristen
is all about motivation
and what the research
shows to be best practices,
she wants to make this session
highly interactive as well.
So please join us in the
chat room at tlk.io/khan.
And I'll put that in the chat in a second.
And you can chat directly
with Kristin, with me,
and with your fellow
educators across the country.
Kristin will be asking you some questions
and she'll take some questions for you
at the end of the session as well.
So that being said, thank you
again for joining tonight.
I'm going to pass it over to Kristen
to share with you seven awesome tips.
- Great, thanks, Jeremy.
And I will echo Jeremy's thanks to you
for taking some time out
of your busy schedule
to chat with us today.
And I hope that you find
the things that I have to share helpful,
and as Jeremy said, please
do also chat with each other,
'cause I know we all learn from each other
and I'd love to hear your
ideas as well in the chat.
So I'm going to start
off by asking all of you
to think about the last
thing you decided to learn,
like a new thing, a new skill,
something new you decided
to try to pick up.
And think about why you
decided to try to learn that.
And if you don't mind sharing,
you can head over to that chat
and just tell us what it was
and maybe in a couple of words
why you decided to take on
that new learning challenge.
And while you're doing that
I'll tell the little story
of what I have recently decided to learn.
So I decided to try to learn origami
because I feel like I have
terrible spacial skills.
Like I can follow the instructions,
like fold here, fold here.
But I don't really understand
how it all comes together
in the end to make a bird or a frog.
So thinking about, I said,
"All right, here's the
thing that I want to learn."
So let's see, we've got
some life drawing online,
some balloon animals, tablets on,
how to use the tablet to
draw on your computer.
That sounds like a good, applicable skill.
Yoga, that's a good one.
Siphoning water out of the pool, oh.
So, cool, it looks like
we have some good things
that people were learning.
Part of the reason I
wanted to tell the story
of what I'm learning is also because
as we speak about what is it
that motivates you to learn,
we're going to come back to these ideas.
But I also had an interesting
reaction from my mom
when I told her what I was going to learn.
And she said, "Oh, I would
never try to learn origami.
"I would be terrible at that."
And it turns out that that reaction
of wanting to try something
that you think you might be good at
and not wanting to try things
that you don't think
you're going to be good at
is one of the founding
principles of motivation.
And over lots and lots
of motivation research,
we can kind of boil down motivation
into some pretty simple equations.
Basically that motivation
is whether you expect
you can be successful at something
and how much you value the task.
And in education research jargon
they call this expectancy value theory.
But really it's just
that we like to do things
when we think we're going
to be successful at them
and there's some value to doing them.
And so as I go through the tips
that we're going to talk about,
they each kind of come back to this.
And so, as you're thinking
about your classrooms,
as you're thinking about different ways
to motivate students,
you can think just about
these two simple things.
How can I help students expect
that they will be able to do this?
That if they try this, they
can be successful at it?
And how do you increase the
value of the task for them?
And so those are the real pieces
that we can kind of come back
to for each of these things
that I'm going to talk about.
So the first one, and the first idea
is to set goals together
and monitor progress.
Because, you know what, it turns
out, nothing makes you feel
like you'll be successful in the future
like having been successful in the past.
And a good way to really mark
whether you're successful
is by meeting a goal.
So there's a success piece in here,
but one of the reasons that
goals can be so powerful
is because there's also a value piece.
And that comes in the
setting goals together.
So if the student has some
input into what the goal is,
that actually increases
the value of the task,
it increases their buy-in
to the task as well.
So it brings success and value.
So that's pretty powerful
in that motivation
equation piece of things.
So thinking about setting
goals is important.
It's important to think about
the, how big those goals are.
It turns out even for adults,
longterm goals are pretty
difficult to keep at,
to maintain all of that work towards them.
We want to set short-term goals
and they can build
towards a longterm goal.
But even for our high schoolers,
we want a specific goal,
probably not to be longer than a week
in terms of what they're going to do.
And we don't want to
have too many of them.
So we want to really boil
down to the key things
that we want to focus on.
What are those together?
And then a couple of pieces.
One is we want to think
about how are we going to see
if we're on track?
So how are we going to
monitor our progress?
Whether that's each day or a
couple of times during the day,
how are we going to know if
we're on track to meet our goal?
And that's the funny thing
to think about with goals
is to give people a plan
when they get stuck.
So the first time you
get stuck, and you don't,
and you're not able to
think about, you know,
I seem like I'm off track on my goal,
how do you get yourself back on track?
And actually talking about
a plan for what to do
when you're stuck,
particularly when we're
talking about distance learning
and the students potentially on their own,
trying to work through some problems,
what should they do when they get stuck?
So setting goals together
and monitoring progress,
that's a good piece.
So when you think about
that thing you just learned,
think about what your goal might be.
I know my goal in the origami
is to be able to make one of those frogs
that you can hit the back of and it jumps.
We'll see if I get there.
But that's what I'm, that's
what I'm currently working on
for this week's goal.
So setting goals, monitoring progress.
And somewhat related to that
is then celebrating success.
So this idea of, hey,
you did it, that's great.
Getting that feeling of
accomplishment is really important.
But the other thing that
this helps us do is reflect,
and it can give us a
moment to stop and say,
"That was awesome, great."
And also, are there things
that, what did you do?
Tell me, where did you
start and where are you now?
And get them to see their own growth.
That's really motivating to see,
yeah, I did actually improve on that.
I did get better.
And then you can also ask questions like
what helped you get there?
What was good?
And you can reflect on
what didn't go so well.
What would be even better if
next time you did this thing?
So building in a little
bit of time to reflect
pays dividends down the road
in terms of helping students
feel like they have the tools
to grow and progress on their own
and build up their own sense of ownership
over what they have.
But again, it comes back
to feeling successful
and feeling like they can be successful
at what they're doing.
So that's the second piece.
The third piece is thinking
about working collaboratively.
So people in general, even
those of us who are introverts,
still like to have a
feeling of belongingness.
And so if we can work
together on something,
we can work and each contribute something
and feeling like I'm
contributing to a piece of this,
that can actually raise
the value of a task
because we're working together on it.
And I know in a lot of
motivation language,
it's tempting to think about
things like leaderboards
and we can create a leaderboard
and kids will be motivated
to get to the top of the leaderboard.
It turns out research tells us
that those competitive kinds
of situations aren't great
for the kids who are
often at the lower end
of the achievements spectrum.
So to be kind of coming in,
you know, in the bottom half
over and over and over again,
that does a lot more to kind
of crush students' spirit
than it does to actually
motivate them to do better.
So, as you're thinking about
how to set up group activities,
think about how you can do that
to encourage peer interaction
and everyone having a contribution to make
towards a class goal,
as opposed to thinking
about individual competition
between different members of
the class and where that works.
And again, this raises
the value of the task
because you're thinking I can move
and I can collaboratively
get to those spaces.
All right, fourth tip.
Emphasize effort leads to success.
So this is a big piece again
about thinking whether you
can be successful or not.
And there's a lot of talk
about thinking about how do we,
you know, growth mindset has
kind of become a buzzword,
but it's based on some sound research
that says that a lot of
students don't believe
that if they work harder
they can be successful.
And having them think
about how that happens
isn't just about, oh, just tell
them they can be successful,
keep working, good effort.
Not going to work by itself.
But what they have found
is actually teaching students a little bit
about how your brain works
and how practice actually does change
how your brain functions can,
along with those kinds of messages,
help students believe that
hard work does lead to success.
And if you're looking
for a little bit of that,
a little bit of that information,
I'm going to give a
little bit of a plug here
because there's actually on Khan Academy,
a course called Growth Mindset,
and there's videos on there
for elementary school students
and high school students.
And I'm going to play a
little snippet of a video
that gets with this idea
of how does your brain actually grow
as you're learning new things?
So this is just a quick
minute of that video tape.
- [Narrator] When you struggle,
your neurons are struggling too.
And that's important because
when neurons struggle,
they lean on each other.
They make connections.
They start to form this
densely connected network
inside your brain
allowing little jolts of
electricity to pass down them
more and more efficiently.
That's thinking faster, that's
your brain getting smarter.
That's your brain muscle
getting swole, kid.
So the next time you say to
yourself, "I can't do this.
"I'm just too dense."
Remember that brain
density is your friend.
In fact, the denser you are
the more connections between
Nellie and her neuron pals
that you've got inside your brain,
the stronger and more powerful
your thinking parts become.
The more you work
through your frustrations
with the right learning strategies,
the more your neurons get
more used to working together,
the closer you are to
being that much smarter.
- All right, I'm going to switch back
to our presentation here.
So what you saw there is that idea
of helping students
understand that it is the case
that as you practice, as you learn more,
your brain is actually changing
and that's what then is going to help you
answer all those questions
and be able to solve those problems.
So it's a big piece
that we can think about,
again, not just kind of praising effort,
but helping students to understand
how it really does lead
to them understanding
and being able to do more things.
So that's step four, tip four there.
Let me go to number five.
So relationships.
So I talked a little bit about
kind of peer relationships.
But the other thing
that is really important
is, of course, your
relationships with students.
And I'm sure I'm not telling
any of you anything new,
but in this distance learning world,
that can be really difficult to form.
So think about how at the
beginning of this school year,
you usually start building
relationships with your students.
And if you're in the chat room
and want to type a couple things
that you've tried this year,
if you are distance or you
have some remote learning,
how you're trying to build
relationships this year
in a distance environment
with your students.
So a couple of things we can do is
one is definitely think about
how you are coming to know
your students as people,
like, what are their, what
are they interested in?
What are the things that they think about?
What are the things they worry about?
What are the things that makes them happy?
Kind of all of those pieces are important
as we start to understand
who our students are.
And as students build
relationships with you,
they actually will be more willing
to do the things you're
asking because you're asking
and they value their
relationship with you.
So that relationship building pays off
both in terms of, you know,
just having good relationships
with your students,
but also in terms of motivation.
And I see that this idea that Julia posted
about being your genuine self,
and that is part of relationship building
is sharing a little bit of yourself too,
being your quirky self,
or sharing a little bit that's different.
And all of that is important
to make it a two-way street
in the relationship of what you're doing.
So want to emphasize that
that is so important.
Think about if there's ways
when you're doing a synchronous call,
that you don't just jump
right into the content,
but you have some time
where you're getting to know your students
and they're getting to know each other
to help build those together.
So lots of things like
I see morning check-ins
and all of those good ideas
for helping to build those up.
So that is number five,
build relationships.
Number six, establish relevance.
So I know this is like the,
one of the top 10 most hated questions.
When am I ever going to use this?
But it turns out that
the value of the task
is really related to how
relevant it is to a student.
And it doesn't mean that
yes, you're going to use
this specific Pythagorean
theorem in our future,
in your life,
but think broadly about
what student's goals are
and think about how the
things you're learning relate
to maybe it's outside interests,
maybe it's career goals,
maybe it's just related to something else
they want to learn how to do.
Any way that you can make the
things that they're learning
relevant to the real world and
applicable in the real world
increases that value of
the task to students.
So really important to think
about how they can connect
what they're learning to their lives.
So that's an important piece,
and do some thinking about it
and be explicit about it
when you're starting a lesson
or you're thinking about
here's the objectives.
And here's where I make those objectives
seem like they're going to be relevant
to what my students care about.
So that is number six.
And number seven.
Let's talk about rewards.
So rewards are tricky to get
right, but they can work.
And in, I know as an adult,
I reward myself when I do things.
When I have to do a long writing task
I break it up and give myself, you know,
a little piece of chocolate
after I finish a little bit.
Lots of folks do with, you know,
with all kinds of exercise,
apps, do things where
they reward themselves.
People who do, you know, personal finance,
rewards after you save a
certain amount of money.
All those things work for a reason.
We do like getting them.
The key is there's a couple
things in terms of the research
about how to use rewards wisely.
So the first is you want to be careful
because students that are
already doing something
because it's really interesting to them,
if you start rewarding
them too much for it,
they start to think,
"Oh, I'm just doing this for the reward,"
instead of doing it because
it's interesting to them.
So we don't want to like kill
that intrinsic internal motivation
by giving external rewards.
But there's good ways to use rewards
that actually don't do that.
So the first is if you have
students that, you know,
aren't that interested, internal
rewards can be a good way
to get someone started.
Or external rewards can be a good way
to get someone started on something
so that then they can experience
that feeling of success.
They can do all of those things
that then kind of move them
towards more internal rewards.
The other things that
are helpful with rewards
is to sometimes make them surprising.
Like here's a little piece of joy
for doing thing that you just did.
So if they're not on a fixed schedule,
it's more likely that
they'll be effective.
Something that's surprising
and different for them.
And the third piece is
don't make them big.
They can be little things.
Also think about, you
know, praise as a reward.
Think about small little
things that someone,
you know, likes to do.
And it goes back to
this relationships piece
about thinking about if
you know your students,
you know what they care about,
you can think a little bit more about
what will be rewarding to them
and what kinds of things are rewards.
But again, not big things, little pieces,
do it sometimes unexpectedly,
and think about how we can
build those, that together
so that we start with some
of these external rewards
to build momentum towards more
internal intrinsic feelings
of reinforcement for doing
what we want them to do.
So all of that, all said and done,
here are the seven things
we just talked about.
So setting goals and monitoring progress,
celebrating success,
working collaboratively,
emphasizing effort leads to success,
building relationships,
establishing relevance,
and using rewards wisely.
So with that, let's open it
up for questions and thoughts.
Jeremy has got the chat
and he's going to feed me
in questions or comments
or thoughts that might be
interesting to talk about.
- Yeah, thank you so much, Kristen.
You definitely sparked
a great conversation
in the chat room.
If you want to join that,
those links are in the chat.
Come over to tlk.io/khan.
You can ask questions right there.
You can ask questions in the,
go to webinar control panel,
but you've got a rock star researcher
and a motivation expert at
your disposal right here.
So any questions, big or small,
Kristen is happy to take them on.
Okay.
So we're gonna start with
a question from Sage.
Sage says, "Kristen, we've got some kids
"who are very hesitant to be on camera,
"which our administration is
actually requiring this year.
"Any good tips to help encourage them
"in this very frightening environment?"
- So a couple things.
So first is find out if you can
try to get a little bit
to the root cause there,
what is it that they're,
is making them hesitant?
What is it that they're not sure of?
So in some cases I've
heard about, you know,
the issue is being nervous
about showing their background.
Like if they live someplace
they're not real excited
to show where they live
and what that looks like
and think about, you know,
are there ways to either,
you know, set up a towel against the wall,
set up using your, depending
what your software allows,
some of the virtual backgrounds.
So, you know, I think a piece
of it is it's that they don't,
you know, like how they look,
is it they don't like the background?
Depending on what that, the root cause is
is probably going to depend
on how you want to address,
you know, what the issue is
and try to encourage them
for do, from doing it.
It's probably, I would suggest
that it's probably not great
to do a lot of commenting
on people's videos
and backgrounds,
unless they're doing
something explicitly fun
to bring attention to it,
because that probably starts
to create a comparison issue
where, you know, oh, they
have this really fun thing
in the background and I don't have that,
those kinds of things.
So, but with, as with lots of things,
if you can do anything to get at the root
of what's kind of going
on there it may be helpful
to figure out how to
then think of a solution.
- Yeah, it definitely seems
like spot-on advice, Kristen.
'Cause it seems like a lot of districts
are trying to find ways to
keep sessions interactive,
but also respect students'
privacy and all that.
And Sage says that's super
relevant in their district.
So that's awesome.
Another question came in and
it said, "Any suggestions,"
this is from Julia, "For
what to do in the moment?
"So like here you are in
your third hour of Zoom,
"the student is starting to hit a wall.
"How do you bring that
extra oomph of motivation
"right when you need it?"
- Yeah.
So I will suggest a little pre-planning.
Some of the things I know for those of us
that are on Zoom lots during the day,
I'm on Zoom calls, you know, all the time,
it helps just to stand up,
like stand up and shake
and get the wiggles out.
There's a lot for, you know,
just staring at that screen is difficult.
So I would definitely
suggest that, you know,
let's all take a break.
Let's everybody stand up.
You can even, you know, lead
a couple of those stretches,
do some arm circles, do some toe touches,
you know, get things going
and just take a quick break.
And honestly, as we're
talking about screens,
the recommendations from the eye doctors
are that for every 20 minutes
you're staring at a screen,
you take a 20-second break
and look at something 20 feet away.
So it's the 20-20-20 rule.
So that can be helpful too,
just giving your brain
a chance to check out.
And then the third thing
that I will recommend
is we actually at, again, Khan Academy,
and, Jeremy, maybe you
can find the link to these
and put them in the chat.
We actually have a little
piece of section of cards
that we call refresh.
And the refresh cards are
just simple little questions
that you can have students do.
Thanks.
Jeremy's put those in the chat.
That just ask students questions
like if 2020 were a food,
what would it be?
Or, you know, draw a picture of yourself
in some crazy environment.
So all kinds of different things
that can be just again, a
good break for the brain,
doing something else,
doing something a little bit different.
- Cool.
And we'd actually asked
that same question.
What would 2020 look like in food form
in one of our webinars a few weeks back,
and I would say teachers
are very creative.
Some people said it looked like haggis.
It looked like spoiled potato salad.
So definitely a good way to get teachers
and students alike feeling motivated.
Okay.
Another quick question
comes in here from Denise.
And Denise says, "One
of the hardest things
"with distance learning is collaboration.
"Now I used to break my
students up into groups
"and have them work together.
"And that was awesome
for building connections
"and also accelerating learning.
"How do we do that in this environment?"
- So this is going to depend on software
and school policies.
'Cause just glancing over at
the chat I see Denise saying
her school doesn't allow
unsupervised Google Meet.
So that makes things a lot more difficult.
So I'll give you the ideal answer
and then I'll do some other pieces.
So lots of software, like Zoom,
actually has breakout rooms,
and you can assign students
to groups of three or four
and have them, they get together.
And you can actually
drop in, as the teacher,
to the different rooms at various times
and see how they're doing
and where those are.
So that's kind of an ideal situation.
But again, know lots of you are,
there's issues with Zoom,
there's issues with district policies,
and there's issues with
how to make that work.
So the, if you were thinking
about where those are,
if you don't have access to
that, here's some other ideas.
One is is there any software
where they're not looking
at each other and not,
you know, not using video,
but are collaborating on a document?
So Google Docs is an example
of that, where, you know,
they're actually in the
document writing and solving,
you know, potentially writing together,
everyone's writing a section or, you know,
putting a section together
and working together on it
and they can talk to each other in the,
potentially the chat, you
know, piece of the Google Docs
to coordinate back and forth at that work.
So there's one thought of, you know,
kind of how to get people
working together on things.
There's the idea of having
just a small group together
with you, but that puts
huge demands on your time
to be able to do that.
But it might be it depending again
on your district policies,
instead of doing two hours
with the whole class,
would it be worth breaking them
into, you know, five groups
and doing four sessions
over that two hours instead?
Again, district policies, I know.
So think about what are the solutions
that you might be able to have
to get around those kinds of things.
Being able to give all of the
students a problem, again,
to work on together in some,
you know, Google document,
something like that, and
then coming back as a whole
and sharing the different solutions
from the different groups.
All kinds of different
pieces to think about.
But it's going to depend a
lot on what software you have
and what kind of constraints you're in
with what your district can do.
If worse comes to worst,
think about your whole group.
And you're, you know,
you're trying to encourage
at least collaboration among peers
when you're all together
in a whole group setting.
- Yeah, so hard to do right now,
but it looks like Tammy and Dusty and Mary
have had some good ideas,
Nearpod, Padlet, Jamboard, Kami.
So definitely explore those.
Larissa has a really
interesting question which is,
"Kristin, do you have any
really practical how-to tools
"to help kids set goals
"and then monitor those on a weekly basis?
"I've always wanted to
do this with my kids,
"but I've never found a
practical way to do it.
"And it always seems so time consuming,
"like so much followup is involved.
"How do I practically
get this off the ground?"
- And I'm sorry, I missed
the, to help kids do what?
- Oh, I'm sorry to actually
help them set goals.
So going back to one of
your very first points.
- To set goals, oh, okay.
- Seems like a great idea in
theory, but how do you execute?
- Yes.
So in thinking about goal setting,
one of the simple things to do is to,
and you can find these, you
know, all over the Internet,
but just to create a little template
that says, what do you want to
accomplish in math this week?
How will you do that?
It helps them think about their plan.
What will you do if you get stuck?
And how will you know if you're on track?
And like just kind of giving
them a simple, you know,
four questions that they can answer
that kind of gets at
those important things
about goal setting that
they can work through.
And if you can have an
individual conversation
with one of them, that's great.
And think about what that's doing.
You can in that first
setting suggest some goals.
So, hey, we want to think
about a reading goal
and we want it to, you know,
how much you're going to read
and what that looks like.
And so how, what do you think we should do
and what that looks like?
So all of those pieces I
think could potentially be,
you know, either collaborative,
you can provide a little bit of guidance
for each of those questions.
But a really simple
template is the best thing
that I've seen.
And there's lots of examples
kind of around the web
of those kinds of just easy
goal-setting templates.
- Great, so I think we're
at the bottom of the hour.
I know it's getting a little
late on the East Coast,
especially during those first
few important weeks of school,
but I want to thank you so much, Kristen,
for sharing your expertise
and wisdom tonight.
Thank you also to all the
awesome educators out there
across the country for joining
and then sharing your own expertise.
This has been a super good demonstration
of learning through collaboration.
So wish you all tremendous success
with the rest of the school year.
And, Kristen, as we end
any final words of wisdom,
any sort of things you want
educators to be thinking about
as they head into a tough school year?
- I just want to first say
thank you again to all of you
and that you are probably
each other's best resource,
so collaborate with each other
and reach out to each other.
And we're here to help as we can.
- Wonderful.
Well, with that being said,
here's wishing you all a great evening,
a great start to the school year
and tremendous success on the road ahead.
Cheers, all.